نحيكم مشاهدينا من جديد اختفت اكثر من 600
مليون دولار من بورصه اف تي اكس الاليه
للسقوط والتي اعلنت قبل ايام عن افلاسنا
محتمل وذلك اثر عمليه سحب غير طبيعيات
تبين لاحقا انها هجوم الكتروني ادى الى
قرصنه كميه كبيره من العملات المشفره
الموجوده في السوق الافتراضي كما يقول
البعض وطلب المستشعر العام لشركه اف تي
اكس من عملاء الشركه والمستخدمين الغاء
تثبيت اي ترقيات وحذف جميع التطبيقات
المتعلقه بشركته والتداولات التي تقوم بها
على الانترنت وذلك خشيه ضياع مزيد من
الاموال واقله تشارك في بيان ان البيانات
على الشركه اثبتت ان العديد من الرموز
المميزه لعمله اتريو يوم الرقميه المشفره
وكذلك العديد من العمله الاخرى قد تركت
محافظه رسم وتحولت الى مكان اخر مؤكده ان
التحقيق جار حاليا بشان التحركات غير
الطبيعيه في محافظ بورصه اف تي اكس لمعرفه
ملابسات عمليات القرصنه الكبيره
[موسيقى]
نفهم مشاهدينا ما حدث لافتئاكس مع ضيفنا
من دبي طلال الطباعه متخصص في العملات
الرقميه اهلا بك معنا طلال في الواقع
السؤال سؤال مليون دولار يقول البعض ما
الذي حدث لاف تي اكس لماذا افلست لان
البعض يلوم العملاء يقول بانه كانت هناك
حركه هجوم وسحب مكثف على الارسنا والبعض
الاخر يلوم بنك ان يقول بانه هناك عمليه
احتلال وتحيل ولكن حضرتك تشير لي بانه لا
هناك شيء اخر سبب اخر ترجعحه
تمام هلا اول شيء انت حضرتك تفضلتي قلتي
هو سؤال المليون دولار بس انا المعلومه
سؤال 40 مليار دولار انه او 600 مليون 600
مليار كم هو الرقم اللي سحب
الشركه تقييمها النهائي كان حوالي 40
مليون عدد الاذاعات للعملاء الي مو موجوده
حوالي 10 مليار ففي تن بلين دولارز من
ايداعات العملاء اللي مش موجوده بس كان
بدي اعلق على نقطه
بتفرق المنصات العملات الرقميه من البنوك
بتستخدم همم نظام همم الجزئي انه اذا
البنك همم عنده ايداعات بنيه بيقدر يقرا
90 منها ويخلي عشره
العملات الرقميه المنصات العملات الرقميه
اي عميل بشتري همم بيتكم هنا من العملات
لازم المنصه تحتفظ بهذا الاصل للعميد اف
تي اكس اللي عملوه غير قانوني وهمم وبخالف
لكل ال- ال- القوانين والتشريعات وراح
يكون فيه همم قضايا اكيد على على المنصه
لان هاستخدمت العملات لاسباب لاستثماريه
او لغايه استثماريه فقط
على مؤسسها ومديرها التنفيذ البنك مع
الصحيح لانه هو على الاقل الثابت بانه قام
بتحويلات من هذه الشركات لشركه اخرى شقيقه
اللي هي انا ميدا
فاليوم هو سام مؤسس شركه
ومؤسس شركه افتياكس اليوم بعالم العملات
الرقميه في المنصه اللي هي بتسمح لك
تتداولي وفي بما يسمى الماركت ميكر او
مزود السيوله اللي هو بيلبي طلبات العملاء
المنصه لازم تكون محايده و ما تتعامل مع
عده مزودين سيوله اللي عملوه اف تي اكس ان
هم كانوا المنصه وهم كانوا مزودين السيوله
فصار عندهم تضارب مصالح مع العملاء
تبعونهم همم وبصراحه تهوروا باستخدام
الاذاعات همم
الزبائن وللاسف اللي صار هياثر على على
نظره العالم العملات الرقميه ولكن لازم
نفهم التكنولوجيا نفسها ما فشلت شركه هي
اللي فشرت وليس همم التكنولوجيا اللي وراء
العملات الرقم اكثر من انه اثر على نظر
المتعامل مع هذه الشركات هناك تضرر كذلك
هناك اضرار لاحقت بهؤلاء المتعاملين ليست
هناك ارصده تسمح لهم به على الا اا التحرك
او على الاقل همم محاوله همم استرجاع
ارصدتهم وبالتالي فيما يخص هذه الشركات
ونحن نتحدث على شركه رقميه لن نتحدث عن
بنوك ان كانت في بنوك مثلا يمكن ان يفتح
تحقيق بالنسبه لهذه الشركه كيف يتم
التعامل مع الموضوع
فهلا اول اشي لازم نفرق انه مو كل
المشرعين نفس الشيء اذا انت عندك شركه
وانا عندي شركه مرخصه من البنك المركزي
البحريني او مرخصه من الحكومه الامريكيه
كثير غير عن ترخيص
شركه اف تي اكس مرخصه بجزر البهاماس وجزر
البرامج اذا انت اليوم بدي اطلب منك انك
تودعي مصاري ببنك موجود بسويسرا او بنك
موجود ببهره راح يكون الجواب واضح على اي
واحد راح تروح همم
مرخص
المفروض مش عارفه ههه
الاكثر همم الاكثر ماذا
الاكثر امانه يعني اليوم الواحد
اعتقدك تتحدث عن الاكثر التسترا على
التجاوزات
سويسرا يمكن بالسابق كان عندها هاي ال ال
السمعه ولكن باخر من وقت 2008 البنوك
السويسريه كثير اكثر شديده يمكن سويسرا مش
احسن مثال لو استخدمنا يمكن همم سنجاب او
البحرين او امريكا
اللي حيصير انه الشركه هتمشي عن طريق
التصفيه اعلنت بانكرا بسي بما يسمى
التشابتر ايفن اللي هو لما شركه تعلن عن
افلاسها
وانا بتصور الشخصي للاسف اي شخص كان عنده
ايداع بي اف تي اكس ااا الفرصه انه يسترد
هذا المبلغ قليله وهذا الدرس انه الواحد
لازم يتعلم انه يستخدم يا منصات ملخص
لها سمعه قويه او انه يكون عنده همم
الاحتفاظ بعملات الرقميه بنفسه بما يسمى
بنوتيورك
على ارض او حاصله على رخصه دوله همم مدينه
القوانين ولكن حتى الموضوع يطرح اسئله
سلامه التعامل مع هذه الشركات الرقميه هل
هذا يضعفها تعتقد يمكن ان يكون لها تاثير
اكيد بالمدى القصير لها تاثير ولكن لازم
نتذكر انه في عندك كثير بنوك بسنه 2008
كانوا مرخصه من الحكومه الامريكيه والبنك
المركزي الامريكي ولكن فشله
فالفشل بالقطاع المالي اذا في ناس تتعامل
بطريقه مو مسؤوله او بتهور راح يصير في
فشل اذا اخذوا مقاطره زياده
القصير اكيد القطاع تبع العملات الرقميه
تخف الثقافيه ولكنها اهميه ال همم
اللامركزيه
نعم او لا يمكن ان يفتح تحقيق جنائي في حق
البنك كمان تعتقد اذا ما سبقتهما سيفتح
اكيد طيب شكرا
طلال متخصص في العمله الرقميه
ولا النقاش دائما بقيه السلام عليكم